こんにちはカネシャ犬この話であなたは泣く月を知っています
スキレット以上の間にエステートでたった3つのトシバロッカー
マドンナノーズ土佐ワウもロック
イーグルボゴタセレモニーは彼らの角度を知っている必要があります
彼らのお金のホーンゴボをノックする
必要がありますほとんど私たちの
犬の机に会社はもう少し高い
コレカラマンザノコーンユニットライチバラクは
ハハコステートと呼ばれています
私が日本でコンドミニアムを購入する過程について話すのにかなりの時間がかかり
ました。私の
コンテンツはすべて常に日本語である
か、完全にスクリプト化されている
か、英語を話すことはめったにないので、これは私にとって本当に奇妙です。
誰かなので
、スクリプトなしで話すのは
本当に苦手なので、事前に謝罪
します。参照するメモを電話にいくつか書きましたが、
そうですね。 どうやって始めたのか、どうやっ
て日本でコンドミニアムを購入するプロセスに入ったのか、
このすべてがどのように始まったのかよくわかりませ
んが、私の常連客は知っていると思いますが、実際
には約1年の双子の子供がいます。
生後約2ヶ月
半2ベッドルームの
アパートに住んでいるので、穴の中でldkに電話するのを待ってください。
つまり
、2つのベッドルームが2つあり、
かなりの基本的なアパートです。 広い
リビングルームと私はこの場所にもツアービデオを載せます。
私たちが移動中の箱を片付けたら、
今はちょっとクレイジーです
が、ええと、私たちは持っています 子供や
物事は
双子であるため、ますます半窮屈になっています。
寝室に2つのベビーベッド
があり、そこに部屋がなく、リビングルームは
完全に彼らの遊び場に捧げられています。
しかし、あなたはそれが彼らの服と彼らのおもちゃでいっぱいになっていることを知っています
sとそのようなものそして私は
他の寝室に私のオフィスを持って
いますが、彼らはいつも居間で遊ぶのにうんざりしていて、
滞在する場所がなく
、私たちが寝ている他の寝室で遊ぶスペースがないためです
彼らはいつも
ここで遊んでいて、私のマイクと私の三脚を私のコンピューターでノックオーバーするのが好きです。
とにかく、私たちが今持っている場所
はとてもいいですが、
日本のアパートの場合
はかなりです 大きい方なので、
毎月約800750usを支払っています。
現在のヨガ8に基づくドルは、
為替レートを通貨にしない
ので、ここでは月に約750ドルです。双子が生まれて以来、
かなり役立ってきたスペースにそれを
支払っていますが、 少し窮屈
で使いづらく、
基本的
にはいつも廊下で遊んでいるのが好きなので
、過去に日本で家
を買うことができるかどうかについて少し話しました。
家や
コンドミニアム、そして私はいつもコンドミニアムにもっと
興味を持っていました。なぜなら、私
は比較的高い建物の上層階のように
素晴らしい
景色を眺めながら住むという考えについて何も知らないのが好きだからです。
そのような海のようなもの私は本当にそれが好きで、私は
いつもそれが私の個人的な
好みなので、それを買うならそれ
は家かコンドミニアムになるでしょう私はコンドミニアム側でもっと意味します
そして
妻は私もそれでかっこいいと言います
が これが可能かどうかはわかりません
私たちが現在の家賃に
月額750ドルを費やして
いる場合、私たちの現在の予算
は、
不動産業者/建築会社からのものであるというこのチラシをメールで受け取ったばかり
です。
Beppuとlloydbetbooの新しいコンドミニアムの数
は、私が住んでいる都市であり、
少しブーイングは私と九州
中のいたるところにあり、このコンドミニアムに600ドルで住むことができると書かれていました。
年貸しでこれについては後で説明します
が、日本での35年貸し出しは普通なので
、それを見たとき、
今ここにあるものと比べて2つの部屋が追加されていて、すべてが ちょうど
いいこの場所は新しく
てここに引っ越しましたが
、彼らが使用した材料を選択
し、バスルームと
床にすべてが素晴らしかったので、
多分私たちはもっと学ぶべきだと思いました
これで行っ
てチェックアウトして
コンドミニアムの物件を見学しました
が、中は
とても素敵でした
が、私がいつも興味を持ってい
たのは、素敵な景色を眺めることです。
分の1は、土地の景色を眺める家の予算の5分の1のような力ではないかもしれません。
そのため、場所は素晴らしく、
内部はすべて真新しく
、とても素敵でした。
あまり見晴らしが良く
なかったので、私たちには向いていないのかわからないような気がした
ので、不動産業者は
、
2、3年前の別の場所がありますが、
見に行きたい
ので、少し古いので
少し安いですが、
個人的な詳細をあまり明かすことはできないので
、これは上だと言って数字を少し曖昧にします
高さ10階以上の建物の上部3階の1つにある上部3階 ビューして
行ってチェックアウト
したところ、すぐに
妻のように恋に落ちたので、この場所に次に何をすべきかを知ってもらいたいと言った
ので、この時点で
ローンの申し込みのように
、日本語でローンや住宅ローンを申請するような調査は行っていませんが、
いつもユダヤ人が目標を話して
いると言うので、それは日本語で住宅ローンを意味するので、
説明しているときでも常にローンと言います
英語での状況とそれは
私が外国語のローンである日本語の単語を言うのに慣れている
ので、ローンを言うときはいつでも
それが住宅ローンを意味することを知っている
ので、ええ、私たちはそこに行き、それを
チェックしました私たちは本当にそれが好きでした
もっと知りたいと言って、彼女
は大丈夫だと言った。それはこの価格
だし、私の財政状況や
そのようなもののためにあまり詳細を述べることはできない
が、これは不動産の価格だと言う
コンドミニアムのパッケージ全体
が、 約1年前のよう
に調べたときの平均的なアメリカの家今は
何なのかわかりません
が、
約1年前に調べたときは同じくらいの
値段だったので、
何度も何度も見ることができます 次回の
ツアービデオのように見えますが、彼女はこれ
だけ
払ってもいいと言っ
てくれました。私は日本で一生を過ごすつもりなので、それは私たちの範囲内だと言いました。
私の状況は劇的に変化しましたが、
私が心配していたのは、それ
が私の金融ゾーンにある場合、私が経済的にできたとしても、
私は外国人なので銀行から融資を受けることができるということです。 君たちに感謝する
ことから私が得た一番の質問
は、あなたが外国人ならどうなるのか
、日本で家を買うことが
できるか、外国人ならローンを借りることができるかということです。
日本人と結婚している私の妻
は日本人です彼女は働いていません でも
、私はすべての収入を私たちに提供します。
すべてのお金は私から来るので、
あなたはそれがすべて私の側に出ていることを知っている本にあります
が、彼女は日本
国民であり、私のビザは
マルチレコードです
配偶者ビザのように
私が日本に滞在できる理由は、私の
ビザは私が日本人と結婚していることを知っているからです。
犯罪などを犯さない限り、基本的に何度でも更新できます。 そういうわけで、
私は妻と結婚してきましたが、
あなたが約4年間の事務処理を通過できるかどうかに
かかっています。それ
については後で詳しく説明しますが、私
は日本に
永住権を持っていません。 米国のようにグリーンカードを持っているのと同じことです。
日本に永住権を持っている場合、
基本的にどの主要な金融
機関も
日本人とまったく同じようにあなたを扱い
ます。 年にta  x声明など
は、日本人の平均的な
従業員を会社などと同じように見
ていますが、日本に9年ほど
滞在しているのに、永住者がいないので、とても奇妙な状況にあります。
何年も申請すれば手に入るかもしれません
が、私たちの問題は、
私たちが本当に
この場所を手
に入れたかったことを知って
いるという
ことです。 始めから
終わりまでは約1年なので、
申し込みをしても、行った日を知ってい
て、
マンションが最初からひざまずいてすみません
でしたが、誰かが急襲する可能性が高い
です。 あなたは
私たちの前で私たちの前にいることを知っていて、
それが日本人であるならば
彼らがそのプロセスを経る必要がないという理由
だけで
彼らは安定した仕事をしている限り彼らはかなり簡単にローンを申請することができました g
お金とブームが起こったので、私たち
は別の状況になりました。これは、
皆さん
が私に尋ねたすべての質問が本質的にこのトピックに関連しているゲーム
ですが、次に
起こったのは、不動産業者が
大丈夫だと言った場合です。 あなたは
それを購入することに本当に興味があります、そしてあなたがローンに承認されればあなたはそれを購入することを約束することができますあなたが
ローンに
承認されればあなたは多分
私があなたをもっと助けることができることを知っています
不動産業者は
、外国人を優遇するためにも興味を持って
います。なぜなら、それは
比較的あなたが知っている2年間市場に出回っていた不動産だったのですが、
とにかく彼らはそれを売りたいと思って
いたので、私は言いました
彼らがローンを取得するために私を助けてくれるようにそれを購入したかった
ので、
私たちが次に起こったのは私がそれと会ったことです私
は銀行の誰かであり
、不動産
業者です あちこちの人 m銀行
は、私たちが会議を開く前に、基本的に過去2年間に稼いだ
すべてのお金の記録を持参する必要があると言っていた
ので、幸運にも私が
責任を負い、
税金などすべてを管理していると言いました。
かなりのお金を稼いで
いるのに、普段の仕事では
なく、YouTubeや
patreonなどから得ている
ので、始めてからずっと正しい方法だと報告してき
ました。 オンラインで
年間2,000ドルのお金を稼ぐ前から
、すべての記録
を持っていたので、それをやってきたので
、日本で不動産を購入する予定がある場合は、これ
を行うことが非常に重要です。
日本の
金融機関は
おそらく
これと比較するものがないので、あなたはすべての記録を持っていると思いますが、彼らは
非常に注意深く、
細部が完璧であることを確認したいので、私はすべてを持っていました
私の論文の そして、あなたはそれを
持っている必要があり、私はそれらをすべて持ってきました、そして
彼はこれらの数字に基づいて大丈夫だと言い
ました 銀行
私たちが購入に興味を示した後、不動産業者が最初にしたことは、私たちに
は
永住者がいないということですが
、地元の銀行に電話して、
誰かが上陸するかどうかを確認します。 あなたに、そして彼女
は私がオラテ県に住んでいる浮き上がっ
た銀行に電話をしました彼女は銀行に電話を
しました
彼らの名前を覚えていない
ので、彼女がくすくす笑った国のt-boneマシンの新しい家と呼ばれる銀行に到着する前に、彼女は3つまたは4つの銀行に電話したと思います。
西日本
シティバンクと私はここに銀行の名前を入れたいと思い
ます 彼らは
貸すのに十分優雅だったので
永住権を持って
いないのに、日本に永住権を持っていない外国人が
いれば、
まずは西日本市銀行に連絡して骨を貸してもらいたいと思う場所のひとつだと思います。
またはNiecyNihonCity Ginkel
彼らは永住者がいなくても外国人に上陸し
ますが、彼ら
が私に再び膝を貸してくれた主な理由の1つは
、私が日本人と日本人と結婚しているからです。
私は
3年以上
経ちますが、それは彼ら
が外国人に貸すときに土地をチェックする大きなチェックの
1つです。それ
は、彼が比較的長い間日本人と結婚していることを知っていることの1つです。
彼らは離婚するつもりはなく
、これだけのお金を稼ぐために働いていることを知っている
ように、おそらく彼は長い間日本にいるでしょう、
そして彼は
これを買うことに興味を示しているので、明らかに
それもfuです 少なくともローンの返済にかかる限り、私が
おそらく予見可能な将来に日本にいるという証拠がある
ので、この
銀行は私
に貸してくれると言っ
ていました。
日本の住宅ローンの場合と同じように
申請プロセスがあります。二重の申請があるので、
最初は事前審査の申請のようなものな
ので、
公式である必要のない一連のフォームを提出するので、
私は パトレオンやユーチューブ、グーグルアドセンスなどからインターネットから直接印刷したたくさんの同様のレコードとその
ようなもの
は私がどれだけのお金を稼いでいるかを示していたので、私が得た収入明細書の
上にあなたが知っているすべてをもう一度印刷しました
私は
通常の仕事から日本の高等教育機関で働いていますが、それ
については少し後で話し
ませんので、基本的に2つの仕事があるので、1つ
は通常の仕事で、すべてのYouTubeパトレオンの
日本語関連のものです。
mulする 収入源をひっくり返すので、彼らは
それらすべての非公式
文書を見
て、あなたがこれだけのお金を稼いでいるなら私たちがあなたに貸すことができると
言ったが、これは単なる
事前審査なので、今あなたがする必要
があるのはあなたがする必要があることです 公式文書でこのすべての情報が必要な
ので、昨年
Xたくさんのお金を稼いだと言ったパトレオンから何かを印刷するのではなく、
代わりに
市役所に行き、市役所の税務署のように行かなければなりません
でした。
ドゴンが昨年、これだけの金額を税金で支払ったというフォームを印刷してもらいます。これは、ドゴンが
収入明細書などでこれだけの金額を報告したためです。
そのため、どこでも税金
を上回っていることを確認する必要があります。
明らかに、
しかし特に日本では、市役所から直接それを取得する必要が
あり、それは
すべてあなたが昨年報告した金額に基づい
ているので、
私が理解していることから
彼らは少なくとも2つを見ているということです
彼は過去2年間そうだったし、私はそれをきちんとやっていたので、私は
再びそのすべての記録
を持っていた。
1年遅れると
、プロセス全体が遅れ
てしまいます。気に入った物件を見つけて、
実際には
少なくとも2年分の領収書が必要で
、市からの領収書などが必要です。 事務所は
痛いので、最初からその上にいることを確認してください。
市役所からすべてのフォームを入手しました。
明らかに
、日本にいる外国人全員を作成する必要があり
ました。
日本で少し
でも収入
が得られるように、1か月か6か月くらいはわからないので、新しい印鑑を作って市役所に登録しなければなりませんでし
た。 家のような日本で大きなものを買う
またはコンドミニアムまたは私は
多分本当に高価な車の
ようなものやボートのようなものを想像しますあなたは
しばしば公式に
登録された収入を使わなければならないので私は
私と私の妻のためにも新しい収入を作りましたそして私たちは
それらを都市に登録しました
住所、名前、電話番号を
文字通り20回ほど書いて、
4つの異なる書類を作成したに違いないので、市役所に行くたびにそのビデオのインスピレーションを得ました。
銀行
が非公式文書の事前審査からすでに承認を与えた後、私たちはすべての公式文書を取得し、
すべての新しい文書をすべての公式文書を銀行に提出し
、1週間後に彼らは私たちに
戻ってきました そして彼らはあなた
が承認されたので大丈夫だと言ったので次に
起こることはあなたがあなたを置く必要があるということです私
はこれについても話す必要があります
ce2006
実際に私はうまくやっているだけです私
は2016年に本質的に定期的に再開しました私は信じていますそして私は
過去1年半のように本当にyoutubeからかなりの金額を稼いでいるだけなので彼らは
見ていました 去年と前年に稼いだ金額な
ので
、その前年の
収入は、オンラインでの収入と、
私が働いている日本の教育機関での収入の合計で1,000ドルくらいだった
ので、今年は
私はオンラインでかなりの金額を
稼いだので、かなりの金額を稼いだので、それがありました。
また、日本の教育機関
も2つの収入源でしたが
、オンライン活動からの収入しかなかった
ので、 安定していなかった
銀行はまあまあのようでしたこれは
あなたが良い軌道に乗っているように金額が良いように
ちょっと
気難しいです 去年はかなりの金額を
稼いだのですが、それ
は私たちにとって良くないので
、交渉の前に彼女の交渉の過程で起こったことの1つです
が、申請の
過程で私は
それをもっと稼ぐために何かできることはありますか？
私はローンの承認を受ける可能性が
あり、彼らはあなたは
すでに日本人と結婚していると言っていましたが、
それに加えて、最初からかなりの金額を下ろすと、私は考えました
私の猿を知っているとはどういう意味か私はそうだと思います秋
は日本語で頭金のようなものだと
思い
ます私は頭金のよう
なものです
少なくとも、あなたまたはあなたが
少なくとも少し質素であり、
お金を節約していることを意味するので、申請プロセスに合格する
可能性があります。 正確な
詳細ですが、dを入れたと言います 自分
の資産の合計値の約10％としましょう。平均的なアメリカの資産
の球場にあると思う場合は、
それ
を10％ポイント1倍し
ます。これは、私が現金に預けた金額であり
、 申請の
過程でたくさんの
ことを話したいの
ですが、もしあなたが日本に住むつもりだと思ったことがあるなら
、倹約してみてください。
新しい服を買わないでください
いつも同じ服を着ています同じ背景を使って
います外出や探索のようになると費用はかかりませ
ん年に一度のように飲むことはほとんど
ありません 本当に
パーティーなどに出かけ
ます私はかなり控えめに住んで
いますとにかく私はカメラのように私のレンズを購入しました
私の三脚は基本的にこれらすべてのものを
使用し
ました
非常に長い間それ
をします 私は日本で不動産を購入するという最終目標を持っ
ていたので、
おそらく
そのダウンピットに費やすことができるお金が
多ければ多いほど、町の支払いにかけることができるお金
が多ければ多いほど、承認される可能性が高くなることを知って
いました 承認されるので
、お金を節約し、大学を卒業してからずっと控えめな生活を送っています。
つまり、10年ほど前なので、10年ほど
前ではありませんが、
10年近く前です。 カバーする良い
別のポイントとええ、私
たちは10％を下げて承認され、私
は銀行に現金でお金
を持ってきました、そして私たちはあなたに弁護士のような誰かと一緒に座るのを好まなければなりません
でした 時間通りにやっ
ている
今、洗濯場のような誰かがその場所を掃除
していて、変な臭いがする別の会社からの電話を期待しているので、この間に電話を拾わなければならないかもしれません。
大丈夫大丈夫とても
良い私は私がrを止めていないことに驚いています
とにかく、これまでのところ、最初からやり直してみ
ました。これらの接線をやめる必要があります。弁護士のように
、公式に鍵を取得するために行くときにお金を入れてください。
あなたが今不動産を所有してい
て、15または20の事柄の書類を
作成し、名前、住所、電話
番号をそのようなものに書く必要があるように、しかし、
もう一度、正しい用語を
教えてください。 英語ですが、私に
もう一度叫びたいです。
シティバンク西ブームのシティ
キングコールは
、私のチャンネルの
ようにずっと素晴らしかったからです。私が話しているジョークがたくさんあります。
日本のいくつかの事柄が少し後ろ向きになっているような奇妙なものであるのは楽しい
ですが、私は外国人だったので
、アメリカ人のようにあなたが知っているすべての研究をしなければならなかったので、彼らはたくさんの余分な仕事をしなければなりませんでした
税金
アメリカ政府は
税金や海外での資産の所有などに関しては
本当に厳しいので、アメリカ政府は本当に時間と労力を費やしているので、そのようなものやアメリカ人はあなたが彼らにあなたの社会保障番号を与えなければならないようにしています
そうそう
、素敵な日本シティバンクへの別の叫び声彼ら
は
最初から最後まで素晴らしかったですそしてそれ
は彼らが私に代わって行ったすべての余分な仕事にもかかわらず
それで彼らにもう一度感謝し
、そして私は鍵を手に入れましたそして私は戻ってきました
先日見たビデオは
大丈夫だったので、これが基本的なプロセスでした。これ
から行うのは
、皆さんがおそらく興味を持っていると思う追加のことについて話すことです。
日本で不動産を購入する
ようになりました。いや、それは
恣意的な注文
です。これらを並べ替える時間
がありませんでした。 今見てくださいがあります
この部屋のいたるところにある段ボール箱は
今の日本での消費税は8％なので、
不動産住宅、
不動産住宅、マンションにも適用されますが
、10％まで上がると
思います。
来年の初めに実装されると思います
3月2019年3月または4月のように言いたいのですが、たとえば
、10万ドルの家を購入すると、
8,000ドルと10,000ドルの差である任意の数になります。
あなたが支払わなければならない税金についてだけ知っていて、あなたが
そうなることを考慮に入れるとき、
あなたは痛みを知っ
てい
ます。 今日本で購入することについて
、あなたは今このビデオを見ていて
、あなたは
今日本で購入できる立場にあります。
これもまた、税率が10％に上昇しそうなので、それは
傷つくでしょう。
たくさんu  mですから、今8％になっている場合は
、10％になりそうです。ポイント2は
かなり明白ですが、自明
ですが、日本語を非常に強力に習得する必要があります。
n1をたくさんゴミ箱に捨てるのは、話すことを考慮に入れ
ていないので、実際には実用的で
はない
と思うからです。これは、言語に関しては断然最も重要なことだと思いますが、
文法ではないという点では、
語彙用語は高度な用語です。
家を購入するときに知っておく必要があり、1つの
レベルはおそらくほとんどの作業状況に適している
とはいえ、1つのレベルでは削減できない
と思います。
また、控除などのことについて話し合うためです。
あなたの納税申告書や、日本語の
この種の用語のような納税申告書の住宅控除のようなものは、最初
からn1の
ようなものか、n2のよう
なものが必要です。  rela 家を買うことになったので、私は
もう10年近く日本に住んで
いるので、しばらく前に住んでいたので、
これ以上追加の調査をする必要はありませんでした。
しかし
、覚えておくべきもう1つのことは
、銀行は自信を持って、
誰
にでもお金を貸してくれることを望んでいるということです。
ほとんどの状況で
実際よりも頭が良くないように見える
ので、自分が何に夢中になっ
ているのかを理解するためにローンを申請するための言語能力が必要なだけでなく
、自分
が誰かのように見えるようにする必要があります
それは可能であり、それを返済する手段を持って
いますそして
私が探しているものであるより専門的
なものはあなたが最初から最後まであなたにとって有益になることを知っているように見えます
そして銀行は見るつもりです
そうして、彼らは私に何度も言った
このようなプロセスはとても良いので
、あなたはこれを理解し、私たちは
あなたにこれを説明する必要はありませんので
、その言語を確実に
知っているので、非常に重要です。
日本の田舎に住んでいる私は
ここで少しミニタンジェントに行くつもりですが、私は東京に1年間住んでいました。私は
東京
の主要な主要大学の1つに留学
しました。 結局、一部が焼け
てしまいましたが、それは主
に、私が
個人的な状況であった関係を通してのようなもの
であり、いわば東京のせいではありません
が、東京は素晴らしい場所です。
1年くらい行くかもしれませんが2年くらいかもしれ
ません
が、
実際に日本に行ったことがなく、日本に行くと日本のイメージを持っている人にとっては、日本
のイメージのように横浜の方がいいと思い
ますが、日本に行くなら
そしてあなたは行きたいあなたはホーを知っています w行って
、私たちを見て、あなたが知っているすべての場所がベースに当たるように変更しましたか？それは私に
はわかりません
が、東京はすべての映画やアニメなどで見られるものだと知っているので、その場所になるでしょう
そのようですが
、東京では
すべてがより高価であり、朝の東京での通勤のように東京ではすべてがあなたに身に着けていますそれは
難しいですそして
あなたが女性ならあなたが私がしない可能性が高い
です 良いチャンス
が正しい言葉かどうかは
わかりませんが
、電車の中で痴漢されたり、そのようなことをしたり
する人々を知っていることについて、あらゆる種類のホラーストーリーを聞いて
います。 日本に住むことができ、素晴らしい医療制度のように日本に住むことのすべての恩恵を受けることができます。
私が日本で好きなことの1つは、
ここに住む平均的な市民は非常に非常に 高いので、
それは基本的にどこにでも行きます
日本では、少なくとも生活水準の点では東京を知っ
ているのと同等の何かを体験するつもりなら
、私たちのわずかな費用でそれをやってください。
唯一の
欠点は、外出できないかもしれないことを知っていることです。
有名な
ナイトクラブが好きなら、
毎週や毎月のコンサートなど
が好きなら、東京はいいけど、住みたいと思うなら、東京はいいね。
日本は長い間東京
は個人差が
ありますが、私にとってはそうではありません。
日本に興味のある人の多くは
、東京に1年間住んでから、
どこかに行くべきだと
思います。 日本から引っ越すと多額のお金
がかかりますが
、日本の他の地域も体験できます。また、
落ち着いていて忙しくないので
、1時間ほど離れた場所に30分から1時間ほど住むことをお勧めし
ます。 主要なものの1つから電車で
横浜、名古屋、大阪、
コルビー、広島のような都市に住むことはお勧めしませんが、目が覚めたとき
は、これらの都市の1つから30分ほど離れた場所に住むことを
お勧めします。
30分でそこに着くことができますあなたは
あなたがコンサートやそのようなものを知っているようにすべての主要なものに
行くことができますそしてあなたは必要なときにCostcoに行くようなものを持つことができ
ますそしてそのようなもの
です 東京の
ような都市の中心部のよう
に住んでいるなら、私が今住んでいるアパート
は、東京にあったら、
おそらく月に2,000ドルで、冗談ではなく、
ここボイドで750ドルです。
私は
今住んでいる街が大好きです。ここで家を買った
ばかりなので、明らかに引っ越すつもりはありませ
んが、ええと、それは
少し正直
です。
便利な
元 私のようなまれな例を除い
て、コンサートを大丈夫
です。税金のためにすぐにさようなら、それについて話しました。
また、日本で購入したい場合は、できるだけ早く結婚するとは言いたくあり
ませんが、これも1つです。
銀行が見ているのは、あなた
は少なくとも3
年間日本国民と結婚して
いるということです。ですから
、日本で誰かと結婚することを知っ
ているなら、あなたが前向きであれば、日本人とほぼ結婚していることを知ってい
ます。 そう
するつもりで
、日本に少なくとも30年か40年住みたいと思っている
なら、当初の予定よりも6か月早く、または1年早く結婚するのが良いかもしれません。
応募できるようになり、日本でローンを組むことができるようになります。
次の金利を念頭に置いておくと、もう1つの良いことがある
ので、多くの人
が35年はこれに夢中だと言い
ました。 実際にはかなり正常で
あり、理由の1つf またはこれは、
現在の日本の金利が
クレイジークレイジークレイジーローであるためです。そのため
、金利について話していたときに両親と話し合ったのを覚え
ていて、変動金利のローンを持っているので、州の金利を忘れています。
今のところ0.85％だと思う
ので
、ゴールドマンサックスなどのオンライン貯蓄口座とは異なり、より高い金利を得る
ことができます。したがって
、日本での35年35年は
かなり正常であるだけでなく、金利は
非常に低くなっています。 そもそもそういうわけ
で、35年かそこらが普通なの
です。なぜなら、
毎月の利息だけに返済する金額は
そもそもかなり低いので、私はすでに
各支払いの3/4のように支払って
います。 直接元本に入る
ので、不動産自体の価値は、
今の日本の金利
が非常に低いことを覚えておくのも良いことです。あなたがアメリカ人なら理想です。
自分のホーンですが、
もしあなたが日本のアメリカ人なら、州から収入を得ることができれば、日本に
いる限りアメリカの税金
を
払う必要はないと思います。
収入が10
万ドルを超えない限り、アメリカの税金を支払う必要はありません
が、
金利はあなたに有利に働き、
はるかに高い金利を提供するアメリカの銀行とのつながりを維持でき
ます。 彼らの貯蓄口座で自分自身で
、または
高利回りの配当のようなあなたが知っているような
もの、または株式市場でのようなもので
さえ、あなたは今アメリカ市場に投資してより多くのお金を稼ぐことができ
ますそしてあなたはあなたの住宅ローンを通してお金を失うでしょう 日本では
料金が低すぎて少し複雑だったので
、きちんと説明できなかったと思いますが、
もう40分
で、すぐに電話する予定な
ので、先に進む必要があります。 しない 彼女のビデオあなた
たちがその大丈夫に多くの興味を持っているなら
私が次に話したいのは
住宅ローンの控除ですので、知らない人のために
私はそれがすべての
ソニーであるつもりはありません さて、私は
あなたが年末にあなたの税金を支払うとき
、そして政府が
あなたが政府に5000ドルを支払う必要があると言うとき、それを知らない人のために
控除が本当に速いので何を説明するつもりです それ
はそのお金の一部を節約する方法であり、そのお金の
すべてを支払う必要はないので
、おそらく米国では住宅ローン控除または住宅ローン控除と呼ばれるものがあります
私
はそれが米国で何と呼ばれているのかわかりません
が 日本で家を購入し、
まだそのお金を返済している場合は、まだ
すべてのお金を支払っていない
ので、住宅ローン控除を申請することができます。したがって、日本の知事に5,000ドルを支払う必要がある場合
繰り返し
ますが、私が持っている金額に応じて、4000ドルを支払うだけでよいのかもしれません。
家のローンを残したので、
あまり多くの詳細に立ち入ることはできませんが、
これは興味のある人にとっては非常に大きい
ので、任意の数のように機能する方法は
、100を費やすとしましょう 家
に千ドルあるので
、頭金にお金を入れないので
、$ 100,000のローンを借りることができます。あなたのローンに
残っているすべてのお金の1パーセントを
、あなたのローンから差し引くことができます。 年末の納税な
ので、
10万ドルの1％は1000
ドルなので、年末に日本政府に5000ドル払わなければならなかったの
は、 アパート
を借りるのではなく、家を返済
するように指示することができます。
年末の税務申告
書からその1,000ドルを直接引き落とすことができます。これは、私のローン
が10万ドルを超えていたため
です。
私がしたローン 今年
は日本政府に支払う必要がないので、払う必要のないかなりの金額が持ち出された
ので、
実際
には、時間があれば、おそらく後で詳細に入るでしょう。
しかし、ほとんどの場合、控除額
は年末に納税申告書で受け取る
ことができる最大の控除額になるため、日本で家を購入する場合は
、 返済しなければならない合計金額の残りの金額に基づいて計算されるため
、最初の1、2年のように実際にお金を節約できます。
したがって、
すでに5
万ドルを返済し、残り5万ドルの場合 そうすれば、私
は500ドルしか持て
ず、その住宅控除は10年間しか使用できませんが
、その10年間の最初の年は
、まだすべて
のローンがあり、残り
はかなりの金額になります。
Jに支払う必要がないこと apanese
政府は、あなた
が支払う必要がないので、あなたはただ貯金し、
多分米国に再投資し
、あなたが銀行やに支払う利子よりも高くなるであろうより多くの利子を取り戻すことができます
日本でのあなたのローンに反対しているので、日本
での住宅ローンの控除に間違いなく注意して
ください。
そのローンからたくさんのお金を節約できます。
35年は普通
です。これについては前に話しましたが
、最後のメモ 私が話したいの
は、不動産
業者が私たちのために銀行を見つけたということです。この銀行は
、不動産を売却しようとしていたために彼らの利益のために永住者がいない日本の外国人に貸し出します。 だから
、
あなたが再び不動産の価格を支払う可能性がある立派な人のように見えるなら、それは何度も知っておくべきもう一つの良いことです
彼らはラールを作るのであなたがそれをするのを助けるのは彼らの利益です
ge Commissionと
あなたに不動産を売るので、あなたが
日本で家を買うプロセスに
あまり精通していなくても、彼らは少なくとも途中であなたに会うつもりです。
お金を稼ぐのは大丈夫なので、
今は45分で、
直接質問には答えていませんが、
実際には、おそらく30または40の質問があるように見えるので、ここは停止するのに適した場所だと思います。
取得し、
それらのすべてに答えるつもりですが、今それを
行うと、このビデオは
20分ほどで1時間の
ようになってしまうので、
ここでビデオを停止します。 質問に
答えるだけの別のビデオを作るつもりです。
そうです、これも
私にとって非常に奇妙なビデオでした。なぜなら、私
は即席の英語だけをやらないことを知っているので
、たくさんつまずきました。
それほどひどいことではありませんでした、そして私は
あなたたちが探していることを願っています ツアー
ビデオに進んでください。このビデオで答えられなかった質問が他にある場合は
、コメントを残し
てください。
それでも別のビデオを構成するので、とりとめのないものになるので、次のビデオにそれらを含めるようにします。 ここで
ビデオをカットしますここでビデオをカットし
ます皆さんがこのすべてを可能にしたように正直にすべてのサポートに感謝します
そして私は十分に感謝を表すことができません
彼は
私が思うに呼んでいた